overnight
our planet has gone from a pale blue
dot to a glistening white snow globe
stretches of earth have become frozen
wastelands that
are completely inhospitable and billions
of people have been left
unprepared for life below freezing
what changes would our planet undergo
what could we do to combat this global
freezing
and would humanity be stuck on a giant
irreversible snowball this
is what if and here's what would happen
if the earth froze
overnight earth has experienced
several ice ages during these periods
ice sheets pulse outward from the poles
and then retract but three of these
freezes
between 580 and 750
million years ago had such an extreme
effect
that the ice didn't retract for
millions of years these are known as
snowball events temperatures
reached minus 50 degrees celsius
and the ice and snow reflected light
into space
as more heat was reflected rather than
absorbed by the planet
the temperature kept dropping if
you could have seen earth from space
back then
it would have looked like a glistening
white ball
eventually the earth thawed you know
otherwise you wouldn't be here watching
this video but
if everything froze back again overnight
could you survive okay
let's start by looking at what new kind
of planet you'd be stepping onto
ice sheets one kilometer high would
cover the earth
even in the tropics the ice would be as
thick
as 10 meters most of the oceans would be
covered in ice
only near the equator or areas with lots
of geothermal heat
could liquid water still exist near the
surface
everything would be frigid it would be
so cold
that most of life on earth wouldn't be
able to survive
especially humans people living in
cold climates would have warm clothing
but
this sudden freeze would be life or
death
for billions imagine living somewhere
like belize
namibia or parts of australia where the
temperature
never drops below 15 degrees celsius
if you lived in those areas you'd be at
risk of death
from exposure to the cold the same would
be true in
many other parts of the world especially
for the poor and homeless or
those with inadequate access to housing
all power and energy systems would be
disrupted and
with no electricity billions of people
wouldn't have heating industries
would grind to a halt even agriculture
or
livestock cultivation would be nearly
impossible
humans would need to band together to
conserve food
energy and other supplies
you would be ready for living on a giant
snowball
if you were a scientist based on an
arctic research station
at a munson scott station in antarctica
the average temperature is minus 82.8
degrees
celsius scientists near the south pole
live in shelters built to withstand the
cold and ice
some even have gyms greenhouses
a movie room and a sauna life in a
shelter though would be
very confined you would only go outside
for
specific tasks to venture outdoors
you would need layers a lot of layers
scientists at these stations wear nearly
nine kilograms of clothing it takes them
about 10 minutes to get dressed any
exposed skin could be frostbitten in
less than 5 minutes
this deep freeze would also make the
earth incredibly dry
as all precipitation would turn to snow
or ice that dry air
could make you feel dizzy you would need
to
constantly thaw snow for water to drink
and the only way to get around would be
with a snowmobile
or if you're looking for a little
recreation
you could try to master kite surfing on
snow dunes
but be careful in earth's lower
latitudes there would be
howling winds this would be another
extreme
element making life difficult
researchers still don't know how the
earth
thought from these previous snowball
events
unfortunately if we wanted to reverse
the freeze
we might have to change our thinking
about greenhouse gases
and global warming we would need to pump
the atmosphere with
carbon dioxide and methane that means
releasing pure gas or burning even
more fossil fuels on the other hand
we could use bombs to detonate volcanoes
around the world
volcanic activity is likely what warmed
the planet
in previous freezes but these solutions
beg the question of what ecological
crises we might create
next like what if we extinguished the
sun
well that's a story for another
what if